yeah you all know what this is from
right I mean it's I've been warned it's
like well the other few things people
told me about and I've caught on to and
I said oh maybe maybe the work it is in
a smart way or a really clever way or
way that's not so cliched and contrived
but no love triangle fucking love
triangle hate love triangles they are so
ah they're just a distraction they delay
what we all know is gonna happen the
only time it can ever work in my opinion
I shouldn't say that but the only time I
have seen it work is in comedy uh when
it's played for laughs I think it's very
very funny but when it's played like no
this is serious drama ah and once again
we got Korra acting like a dumb ass at
the very end she's gonna realize a
problem I'm just sick of this formula
come on you know and the the episode
before the few episodes before we got
this build-up with uh you know with a
man who's going to you know like destroy
the Bender's they can take away bending
power and stuff and what's enas the big
confrontation with her say you're gonna
be the last to go down and she
confronted her her fear and saw that she
was afraid and Wow
what's next oh let's just go to that one
room where they've been challenged you
know where they fight each other and
that's gonna be the episode you know and
they're moving up like in the
championships and can't they get a
different room can't they get a new
design oh okay so this episode is
probably not as bad as I'm making it out
to be but it's just Oh God and you got
the bully there's a bully in this nose
like oh you smell that
that's the stench of losers I'm like did
I really hear that like the most generic
you know well what the hell is that
movie is I think it's go real steel I
had Hugh Jackman is the fighting robot
the Rock'em Sock'em robots which is a
phenomenal comedy it's a terrible drama
that's a phenomenal comedy it's a great
throwback to all those cheesy pieces
shit
not piece of shit but those really corny
80s fighting fills you like rocky for
command or the big muscle-bound movies
and it's it's like that it's like I'm
watching that but it's not trying to
really be that funny it's trying to
actually serve be legit and it's just so
wait you won't like the guy from back is
like it was like this sleek very
feminine Asian man was just like I live
in you down it's exactly like that
except throwing a little Nelson Muntz oh
okay well what's actually good about
this episode I deem omit to the name of
it the spirit of competition is what
this is called it focuses a lot on the
bending and it's not even one triangle
it's like a love octagon you know
because it's like you got the brother
who's in love with Cora cores in love
with maka maka is in love with this
other girl who's the daughter of the you
know whatever NV Ford and it but Monaco
also is kind of in love with Cora but
isn't quite sure and no and and they
want that stupid thing where it's like I
hate him why should I like him it's just
oh don't do this don't go make Ryan
Julia Roberts movie on us that's what
she's reminding us she's reminding me of
all those like you know sort of late 90s
mid 2000 Julia Roberts movies where it's
like I'm gonna act really stupid but you
know I'm clumsy but I have a heart of
gold so forgive me for my mistakes even
though they're really stupid and no
person to write my would and that's what
this feels like to me it feels like bad
mid-2000
Julia Roberts film with fire and stuff
at Joe's movies would be a lot better
there's throwing fire but nevertheless
it's still tough to stomach um and at
times it's kind of playful ass like I
guess the brother when he finds out is
like they play a more comical but it's I
don't think it's that funny I think it's
more like awkward and like kind of sad
but there make him go really over the
top of it
you're not my brother and I'm like why
is this funny why are they playing this
up as a joke you know I mean it's even
though like I said I think it's funnier
when they're done for labs it's more of
hey look at these three terrible people
doing really stupid terrible things uh
garbage truck um garbage truck that's
like ice cream good give some garbage no
again does a big hitting that 1v1 get it
but excuse me mmm cough cough so uh yeah
so so you got this love triangle going
on at the end they kind of come to a
resolution ish in this one episode which
I guess give them credit I like that
they kept it short but I'm just seeing
this formula and and that was something
that like Avatar even when we're
starting to get a formula it's sort of
broke it very quickly you know like like
with the chase aspect or they find a way
to do variations with it or add
something new to it and this just seems
like you got the love triangle you have
the the sports cliches you have that
they can't get along and they have to
come together at the end you got the
really fast resolution you have the
bullies it's it's Mighty Ducks I'm
watching the avatar version of Mighty
Ducks and I don't want to see that I
want to see the stuff they were building
up before um and I see new locations
please you can still stay in the movie
but give me even you can do the
competition which it looks like they're
still gonna do because at the end of
this like the big cliffhanger is oh no
those guys are really good are we gonna
win the championship there's a fucking
guy who can take away betting powers as
this terrorist and a badass awesome
villain and like the big cliffhanger on
this one is oh no the other teams pretty
good
oh but what I was getting to is even if
you're gonna keep it in that damn room
or that damn game change up the set and
in the whatever the big championship of
the tournament make it bigger add stuff
do something I
him you're getting some really nice
angles and that's great but I am tired
of looking at the same places just Oh
change it up I mean that is it I like
the new stuff that they're doing with
this don't get me wrong I like that
there it's okay to keep it in one place
but it's just to change it up do
something different you know just moving
the camera angle down here or up here or
down here I mean it's like I'm just
tired of looking at it um so that that's
sort of them despite everything else
like I say I'm not the fan of the love
triangle or the bullier I mean those
those are like two things I really
really hate together in one episode um
it when it's not done for laughs uh so
oh god I even had the guy like he he
comes in he sees them kizi he has the
flowers I'm like oh my god are you
serious the people who brought us avatar
brought us the owl know uh and the other
thing to it that I was actually liking
uh the date they were going on with the
brother
gambling in the name but and how they
were doing the belching contest and so
I'll thank you start liking them as a
couple but it looks like they're
building up that maybe her and Marco
might be the couple or not now he's
going back to the other girlfriend that
I don't know will die or something if
somebody has to die and this is usually
how works
um I am but you got him do like the
flowers and they get blown away and he
sees them kiss I'm just like yeah talk
about Pearl Harbor soap operas bullshit
uh and it's it cuz it started off with
him just saying I you know Cora I just
don't feel that way when she confess I
thought oh maybe they're not gonna go
that really cliche wrath I thought they
serve builds it up like they're going to
but they're not gonna go that route and
then they go they route it's they really
may look like they weren't gonna do that
and then they do that and it's not it's
not fun it's tedious it's annoying it's
boring and I'm not a fan I'm sure
everyone was waiting for this V long
Break about it say what no well there
you go what now that that's my raising
and shaking my fist huh so like I said I
liked it when Korra and the brother were
together that was nice um and the
bending competition I'm already pretty
sick of it sore like the stupid
Quidditch matches and Harry Potter you
see it once it's like well went over so
well in the first movie let's do it
every single fucking movie after and
let's change nothing about it it's the
exact same goddamn game every time
except hey there's a character there's a
new character watching it's just the
same thing so if you like that sort of
sports movies stuff I mean it's still
well animated and everything I cool it
just bores the sin out of me so yeah
there it is not not a fan of this one
and I like most of the changes they're
doing uh but the one thing I really
think is missing is I think they should
really start changing up the locations
at the very least how they look have
them redesigning a place we're changing
something up or maybe like like I said
in the tournament of the championship
like have them actually add something to
dress it up different or take it to a
different room but just something I'm
just as pretty and nice as these angles
are and the animation is it's still the
same goddamn place and there's only so
long you can look at the same goddamn
place for something that's supposed to
be action adventure fantasy you know
cool visuals there's only so long you
can look at it so and I know it's
pointless me saying do that because it's
done I'm watching the DVD but um yeah
that's just and I know the second
seasons practically done so it's
pointless to say that but that's the
issues I have with it so if you like the
sports element a love-triangle good for
you not a fan myself so um yeah that's
about it I'll see in the next episode
probably see more bending there too